the stellar cast of The Hunger Games
reunites for the final time as Katniss
makes a last stand against President
Snow in the Mockingjay part 2 I'm John
and this is 20 things you probably
didn't know about the Hunger Games
Mockingjay movies for protection
designer Philip Messina the most
complicated set to create was the
capital's tunnels which are about 5 foot
high making it a tough location for both
cast and crew who also had real fire and
water cold complex fight scenes and 20
pounds of waterlogged gear to deal with
during those scenes in fact the action
in those scenes was so intricate that
before filming began the entire thing
was storyboarded and choreographed and
filming took place over the course of
three weeks on a soundstage in Atlanta
Oh in those nuts that Katniss and Cody
battle with were actually brought to
life thanks for mix of real stuntmen on
set and CGI the assault by lizard nuts
wasn't just the terrifying moment for
the movies characters it also got pretty
scary for actor West Chatham who played
cameraman caster who films district 13
proposed with his brother Pollux and
director Cressida while filming a scene
where one of the mutts attacked his
character Chatham nearly drowned as a
stunt performer accidentally held him
under water a number of other actors
also sustained injuries during the
tunnel sequence liam hemsworth who plays
gale hurt his back after being thrown
against a wall and badly bruised his
hips after rolling over steel grates for
multiple takes and those same great sled
to Josh Hutcherson who plays Peter
fracturing his knee actor Sam Claflin
loved having the chance to wield Phenix
Trident against those monstrous mercs
and before filming part 2 he spent time
practicing with broomsticks to keep up
his skills and although Claflin found
Mockingjay part 2 the most physically
demanding of the Hunger Games Movies he
says his biggest challenge was actually
the dance scene at Phenix wedding to
Annie Cresta as he absolutely hates
dancing the map projected by the hollow
that Katniss and her team used to avoid
traps in the capital is based in part on
the layout of Frances capital city Paris
were filming for some scenes in the
Mockingjay movies took place for example
the scene where a pod releases a deluge
of black oil on Katniss and her team was
filmed in these faster brushes a
postmodern apartment con
in a Parisian suburb and for many of the
scenes set in President Snow's mansion
including his office the filmmakers used
a mansion not far from Paris called the
Chateau d'If Wazza speaking of snows
office the rug in that room was woven in
China especially for the production and
measured 45 feet remember the podium we
saw President Snow standing out in The
Hunger Games Movies well the filmmakers
actually destroyed that prop after each
film only to rebuild it for the next one
oh and by the way it may look pretty
sturdy on screen but in reality it's
made from cheap lightweight materials
like plywood and styrofoam for the look
of Katniss's Mockingjay outfit costume
designers Curtin Bart drew on Japanese
archery gear specifically they're
asymmetrical breastplates because
Jennifer Lawrence was the outfit in a
number of different scenes its function
of flexibility were as important as how
it looked so at the first costume
fitting she ran around with her bow and
arrow so that Curtin Bart could work out
where and how the outfit needed altering
for example they built an armed guard
into the costume on Lawrence's shooting
arm when they realized that the
bowstring was hitting her forearm
whenever she shot an arrow when creating
costumes the district thirteens
inhabitants designers curse embarked
looked to world war ii london for ideas
they especially kept in mind the wartime
restrictions placed on the garment
industry to save fabric for example the
number of buttons on clothes and the
amount of pleats in dresses for Effie
trinkets distinct take on districts er
teens clothing curtain parts were
inspired by their experience of New
York's club scene in the late 1980s and
the often eccentric fashion of American
socialite Edith Bouvier Beale who is
also known as Little Edie and featured
in the 1975 documentary film Grey
Gardens by the way the Mockingjay movies
are not the first time that costume
designers Kurt and Bart have worked with
director Francis Lawrence they also
worked with him in 2001 on the music
video for Britney Spears song I'm a
slave for you after taking care of
Elizabeth Banks whose makeup for the
first two films in the franchise makeup
designer V Neal decided to place Effie
Trinket appearance in the hands of her
colleague Nicoletta skarlatos to ensure
a fresh perspective and a suitably
different look for the ever-changing
Effie and the final two movies
transforming actress Jenna Malone into
Joanna took three hours of the makeup
each day which included putting on a
bald cap doing flesh toning and
prosthetic work around her neck and
adding cuts and bruises Jennifer
Lawrence's young nephews Burr and
Theodore Laurence play Katniss and
Peeta's children in the epilogue scene
in Mockingjay part 2 burr is a child
with Josh Hutcherson whilst Theodore who
is just nine months old when the movie
was shot is in Jennifer Lawrence's arms
now which do you think was the best film
in the quadrilogy and why and would you
like to see the Hunger Games franchise
continuing some way if so what would you
like to see tell me in the comments
below so guys if you'd like to see more
videos like this do please subscribe
like and share my next videos will be
things you probably didn't know about
ant-man and things you probably didn't
know about star wars the force awakens
thanks for watching and see you next
time you big a movie lovers